wir schreiben den sechsten tag von
putins blutigen krieg in der ukraine und
an diesem sechsten tag julian da kommt
der tod wieder aus dem himmel wir
schauen direkt auf die aufnahmen und du
erklärst uns was genau wie hier sehen
und wie genau hier gemordet wird ja
heute morgen ich muss sagen es war
schockiert als ich die fotos dahin habe
ich stand vor diesen vor diesem haus
direkt vor der pandemie das was wir
sehen ist ein einschlag im
regierungsgebäude von kreativ genau im
zentrum der stadt wir sehen hier erster
dritter 22 um 81 gab es hier den angriff
wie gesagt ich war schockiert weil ich
ich kenne leute in der region dort ich
hatte eine konferenz direkt daneben das
ist der größte platz europas von der
quadratmeterzahl und an einer an einem
ende des platzes direkt dahinter geht es
in die altstadt haben wir dieses
regierungsgebäude und wir sehen wie dort
diese diese rakete einschlägt und man
kann sie tatsächlich auch auf dem dürfen
genau festgehalten dass fertigkeiten
sagen weil wir sehen tatsächlich hier
auf diesen aufnahmen wir markieren es
einmal wie diese rakete vom himmel kommt
dieses gebäude trifft unten menschen auf
dem weg zur arbeit menschen die ins büro
kommt vielleicht auf dem weg zur arbeit
auf dem weg zum einkaufen und dann eben
vom himmel diese rakete was was ist das
für ein geschoss
das ist noch nicht hundertprozentig klar
meine analyse deutet darauf hin dass es
sich hier um einigen marschflugkörper
vom typ kaliber handelt wir haben einen
einzigen einschlag gehabt es ist also
kein wie wir gestern gesehen haben
mehrfach raketenwerfer angriff der ein
großes gebiet
bombardiert sondern es ist ein einschlag
ein einzelner einschlag eines einzelnen
geschosse wir sehen auch dass relativ
lang ich würde schätzen so 56 meter und
auch relativ breit wie breiter als eine
grad rakete und dass wir an einzelne
einschlag haben und dass eben übrigens
daneben geschossen hat es hat nicht das
gebäude getroffen das hat direkt davor
die passanten getroffen hat die
zivilisten getroffen dass es auf ein
regierungsgebäude trotzdem gerichtet ist
das spricht ja dafür dass wir hier einen
gezielten angriff mit einem maßkrug
körper haben das heißt also jemand hat
im video sich angesehen wie diese rakete
wie dieser marschflugkörper in der
ukraine einschlägt und dass das ist die
folge wir springen in das haus rein und
sehen diese absolute zerstören die
fenster raus gesprengt durch die
druckwelle und über die zerstörung und
tod auf der straße ja vielleicht kann
man das gleich mal anhalten wenn es nur
nach draußen zeigt um das auch noch mal
zu verifizieren einfach die leute sagen
hat teilweise ja es ist das überhaupt so
man sieht jetzt wovon ich gesprochen
habe deren gedanken aber der größte
platz europa ist ein riesiger platz für
größer als der alexanderplatz
beispielsweise in berlin hier vorne
dieses aktivisten häuschen was wir
gerade gesehen haben von mit so ein
kleines zelt in der art was da aufgebaut
wurde und wir sehen auch auf den anderen
bildern dass das haus selbst nicht
getroffen wurde das heißt die ganze
fenster wurden rausgeholt für durch die
druckwelle und ja dann auch wieder nach
innen geht aber die explosion selbst hat
auf dem fußgängerweg davor stattgefunden
und wir wissen mittlerweile dass es
mindestens neun tote hier gegeben hat du
hast gerade gesagt der schütze der hat
auf einer videokamera auf einem video
monitor diesen abschluss am ende gesehen
wie läuft das ab was kann der sehen was
gibt der ein an zielkoordinaten
genau also es gibt verschiedene
möglichkeiten diese kaliber abzuschießen
entweder da guckt jemand tatsächlich in
eine kamera ein und sieht bis zur
letzten sekunde wie das passiert oder
wir haben zielkoordinaten die eingegeben
werden wie du gesagt hast es gibt auch
die möglichkeit mit einer drohne in der
nähe zu fliegen und mit einem laser
sozusagen auf dieses auf dieses ziel zu
blenden und dann sieht man von der seite
als als schützer sozusagen die seiner
rakete einschlägt da gibt verschiedene
möglichkeiten wie die kaliber
einschlagen können in jedem fall ein
gezielter angriff auf ein auf ein
ziviles regierungsgebäude auf kein
militärisches hier die stadt attraktiv
die leidet seit tagen wir wollen uns
eine andere szene angucken von gestern
die den einsatz von streubomben
kommentiert bin ich drück einfach auf
play und du beschreibst uns was genau
wir jetzt sehen
das ist einer der großen angriffe
gestern mit streumunition auf die stadt
wir hatten das schon erklärt da werden
also raketen beschossen mehrfach
raketenwerfer die dann in einigen
hundert meter bevor sie das ziel
erreichen viele viele kleine bomben
loslassen inzwischen 50 punkten und
teilweise sind sogar 100 punkten kommt
auf die rakete an die dann verteilt
werden und jeder davon ist tödlich also
jede wir haben gestern leute gesehen
abgerissenen händen mit abgerissenen
füßen so was passiert wenn man wenn man
von so einer bombe getroffen wird und
ganz klar wir haben auch die munition
gesehen dass es anti personen monetäre
und die ist direkt gebaut worden in der
sowjetzeit um eigentlich natürlich gegen
armeeverbände vorzugehen putin setzt sie
einen gegen zivilisten gegen als terror
gegen zivilisten schauen sie einmal
gleich hier auf diese stelle hier autos
geparkt und stellen sie sich vor sie
sitzen in diesem auto drin und dann
einfach einmal abwarten wie dann geben
genau dort eine dieser streubomben ja
scheinbar willkürlich einschlägt aber
wenn man eben in diesem auto am ende saß
dann hat man keine chance hier zu
überleben wir schauen uns doch einmal
das ist vor ein paar tagen schon gewesen
aber dokumentiert doch ganz gut diesen
streubomben einsatz hier markiert von
unseren kollegen von berlin cat wo
überall ebenso ein geschoss am ende
einschlägt und ja am ende tötet davos wo
es einschlägt warum setzt man sowas ein
warum sitzt man sowas gegen zivilisten
ein ja vor allem wir können uns ja mal
angucken was wir sehen wir sehen hier
einen kindergarten das ist ein
kindergarten ja wir sehen hier die die
rutschen auf den auch mein sohn gerne
spielt wir sehen hier den sandkasten und
wir sind hier tote kinder und erwachsene
die also gerade in die kita reingegangen
sind dass man kann sich das kaum
vorstellen also das ist ein sony gewesen
und ich glaube schon am dritten oder
zweiten tag des krieges und man sieht
hier wie wie das aussieht also wie du
gesagt das ist 123456 einschläge die
jetzt sichtbar sind wenn es zum beispiel
im gebäude reingeht dann sehen was er
von außen nicht aber so setzt putin
seine waffen ein dagegen schulen und
kindergärten gegen schulen und
kindergärten kaum zu beschreiben und
auch schwierig da die richtigen worte
für zu finden wir schauen auf diesen
konvoi der den ganzen tag über uns
beschäftigt wie siege militärfahrzeuge
auf dem weg nach kiew russische
militärfahrzeuge natürlich etwas was
sehen wir hier und vor allem wieder
auffällt diese fahrzeuge in dreifacher
reihung 123 nebeneinander auf dem weg
auf dieser straße ja
diese aufnahmen sollen von nördlich von
kiew sein ich glaube posthume hattest du
mir vorhin gesagt können erstmal hier
drauf bleiben um dann zu sehen wir haben
schon festgestellt dass so groß dann hat
soviel militärtechnik zusammengezogen da
das das ist offenbar nur wenn drei lkws
nebeneinander auf diesen dünnen straßen
fahren das ganze überhaupt bewegen kann
im land das ganze ist jetzt 16 kilometer
nördlich der stadtgrenze von von kiew ja
angeblich bewegt sich dieser combo auf
kiew zu
auch mir ist noch nicht ganz klar was
das ganze soll weil also also da eben
habe tatsächlich nur lkws gesehen ja was
da drin ist unklar hier sehen wir jetzt
auch was anderes ich gibt es den stift
so genau hier sehen wir auch lkws aber
wir sehen teilweise dass sie zum
beispiel hier artillerie ziehen wir
haben also wagen hinter sich hier sehen
wir auch dass hinter den lkws kleine
wagen sind und am rande sehen wir auch
hier das sind schützenpanzer das sind
also doch fahrzeuge zumindest im kongo
absichern gegen angriffe wie du oder ich
glaube keiner hat das vorhin gesagt dass
wenn die ukraine die möglichkeit hätten
und noch die chancen hätten dort zu
schießen und noch die waffen hätten dann
wäre es glaube ich ein leichtes hier
anzugreifen ich befürchte nur allein sie
haben die nicht mehr absolut absolut wir
wollen uns einmal anschauen wie das dann
aussehen würde wenn man die die chance
hätte zuzuschlagen aufnahmen einer
ukrainischen drohne von vor wenigen
stunden die eben zeigt wie hier was
genau wird hier ins ziel genommen
genau also was wir hier sehen ist wieder
eine bayraktar krone türkischer
produktion und das feiern die ukraine
ganz besonders denn was wir hier sehen
sind flugabwehrsysteme angeblich
modernen flugabwehrsysteme solche die
2014 den fugen 17 über ausdruck einer
abgeschossen haben und dabei 298
menschen getötet haben also buchs das
thema die als flugzeug gelten aber die
ukrainische drohne wie sehen ist kann
hier ohne probleme diese systeme
ausschalten dafür gibt es zwei
möglichkeiten wenn man den türken glaubt
dann ist ihre drohne unsichtbar da bin
ich mir nicht ganz sicher ich glaube
eher dass das die noch nicht aktiviert
waren das heißt die die rosenbaum hier
noch erst das auf das dauert offenbar
tage weil die in so schlechtem zustand
sind
dass die ganzen radar es funktionieren
dass die raketen funktionieren dass wir
über den menschen sitzen und so das
funktioniert als ich automatisch das ist
alles durch mir nicht vergessen technik
aus den 80er jahren ja sagt ja am ende
noch mal wieder ein sozusagen hier eine
größere explosion im anschluss folgt
genau das ist ganz interessant auch dazu
erst die bayraktar drohne die erde
relativ kleine sprengkörper hat aber
gezielte und gemein ganz genau auf den
meter genau sprengkörper und danach eben
nach dieser kleinen explosion sind
irgendwann die gesamten raketen dieser
einheit hochgegangen und damit eben
haben eine große explosion dort um
mehrere fahrzeuge wurden zerstört das
heißt julian wir haben die theorie dass
womöglich dieser konvoi aktuell noch
vielleicht geschützt wird durch ja
technologie womit man sich gegen
drohenden gegen kampfjets verteidigen
könnte und deswegen dieser konvoi
aktuell noch nicht so angegriffen werden
kann wie wir das zum beispiel gerade bei
den bug system gesehen haben das ist
eine möglichkeit dass das der verteidigt
wird ich persönlich habe nicht gesehen
verteidigungstechnik ich glaube einfach
sind zu viele es ist einfach so viele
die ukraine kann sich aktuell an
vielleicht drei vier fronten wirklich
verteidigen kann wo man mittel hat und
an allen anderen fronten so ist es
leider auch im land rücken die russen
relativ ungehindert vor lasst uns zum
abschluss einmal auf tierschauen also
der konvoi der nähert sich in
irgendeiner form von hier oben ganz
genau einige medien melden nun analyse
der satellitenbilder dass er etwa hier
ist wie es ansonsten der frontverlauf um
kiew zum abschluss kann auch ein
bisschen mehr rein geht absolut damit
wir das zeigen können wurden aber danke
danke danke
genau also genau wie du gezeigt hast du
hier oben etwa soll sich dieser
kontrolle befinden allgemein geht geht
die front wenn man es uns mal hier
angucken etwa etwa hier lang auch und
das interessante gestern haben die
russen ja versucht die autobahn
abzuschneiden am 06 heißt jetzt hier da
haben wir heute morgen aufnahmen der
ukrainer gesehen makarov wurde da
zurückerobert das heißt da wo es ganz
ganz kritisch wird sag ich mal haben
dass er die pforten von kiew gesehen da
versuchen die eu kann sich zu
verteidigen und versuchen die russen
zurückzuschlagen aber sie können es eben
nicht überall auf einmal da hast einfach
für sie unmöglich sondern sie versuchen
die ganz kritischen infrastrukturen zb
kiew oder aktiv zu schützen aber man
kann nicht 10 20 30 kilometer hinter der
front auch noch parallel angreifen
automatische analyse von julian vielen
dank ihr wir schauen natürlich weiter
den ganzen tag auf die lage in der
ukraine und in und um kiew und hier geht
es jetzt erst mal weiter mit den
aktuellsten entwicklungen